330 creaking her name this is outer
space Brendan here with media or Randy
hello solar system Chris Fairbanks may
absorb yeah we're chris is going to be
our guest today and this is a this is
the bone zone podcasting accidentally
turned into tuned into thanks to
everybody who came to boston and thanks
to tim for sponsoring it and also if you
want to use lift if you never use lift
it's like uber it's a rideshare thing
lift ly ft download their app put in
bone zone all caps all one word be 0 nez
0 NE and you get twenty dollars off your
first ride if you want to see me and
Randy perform stand-up comedy in the
California area we're going to be in the
irvine improv which is a suburb of Los
Angeles October 30th 31st and and
november first just one show and night
go to irvine improv google it figure it
out if you want free tickets um you
probably figure that out too um and if
you want to know where i am i finally
got some dates up on my website and my
websites now Randy dash Libke com what
happened it would used to be Libke Randy
and got a slightly better one I don't
know yeah you did get a slightly Iran
man ran my urban Randy I don't know I
look into that but I'm gonna be near
chapel hill north carolina November
twelfth I'll be and Dallas and Houston
the 21st and 22nd and then yeah that's
it for now there's supposed to be some
may be a show before that and after that
and i'll let you know once i know
officially chris yam what about me you
go chris is going to be in denver do it
this weekend yeah yeah wednesday through
sunday on going to put those dates on my
website Chris Fairbanks com or you can
go to Twitter after
Fairbanks to find me tweeting about each
show the day of the night of them
cinnamon roll Chris Fairbanks and also
mark your calendar the middle December
25th it's going to be Christmas oh yeah
christmas is coming oh my album is out
now so if you want to you know it you
know it would help me go to iTunes and
rate and review my album yeah and if you
want if you want to buy it you can buy
it there you can bike CC direct I think
it's a little bit cheaper there where
you can just listen to it on Spotify to
modify can stream it for free we plug
New Year's Eve in New Year's Day Oh new
january-december 31st up until midnight
it'll be a new years eve celebration
following day and then the following day
is New Year's Day so that'll be 2016
will be starting January first of this
year of next year yeah so mark that in
your calendars also before all that
Thanksgiving Oh a polymer American
holiday with the UH November 26th and
proceeding that also halloween October
thirty-first and that's one of the
nights Randy and I'll buell bit ly
irvine improv oh that's on halloween yes
me and Randy will be dressed as ghosts
actually won't even know if it's really
us yeah okay we're talking about new
years that's in junior that's that's
getting that's creeping up on
Valentine's Day they're februari 14th
that's getting close to that yeah so
mark your calendars yeah daylight
savings time 0 is a starts today too and
I just want to add a note to that unless
you're in Arizona oh yeah yeah gays gay
twins gay brothers all right all right
well okay I'll just be quiet until you
interact with me yeah might be pretty
late yeah it might be a while so you
want to just sit tight yeah I remember
last time
hello my pretties this is a witch hahaha
i captured Rendon and Randy I'm gonna
put a curse on them and make them into
friend to snakes and toads how will make
Randy's dick grow twice its size sigh
hey everybody don't be scared this is
old BW the black thriller and I'm here
with uh your boy the rand man urban
Randy hey did I scare you with the witch
stuff scary as hell see what these on
sound like this is sounds like comedy
audience we're here with urban or way
what's your what's your dj name um like
from like a urban radio station people
always call me Chris the masta f banks
and master f banks yeah thanks Izzy for
all that is good to Chris the master f
pinks the masta ass spanked uh best are
ya oh it should be mass and then star
that star oh yeah math banks that's kind
of a long it looks better maybe a dollar
sign for the US and banks oh that's a
given yeah yeah and the X for the ANC's
and for Chris I know it starts with an
exit it's just to see like a cent sign
okay i was thinking like Christina did
xtina like xmas oh yeah Christmas you
should you're right oh I never got that
yeah we're like a criss cross I guess
but they do it for xmas yeah I never got
the Christmas yeah so I've seen a
comparison next Aguilera secret it'd be
X Fairbanks maybe I'll be xed oh
yeah xtopher have you if you took me a
long time to realize all those
billboards where it's just a guy that
looks like a bartender mmm and it's just
a picture of them they all look the same
and then it says some mom nihon e in
Vegas or whatever it's a DJ oh yeah yeah
oh there's a bunch of DJ billboard that
makes less sense to me than all these
youtube if you two billboards DJ vouloir
DJ's are the biggest fraud and I mean I
guess you got to mix things up or
whatever like you put together little
mix tapes and then you play them off
your laptop but when I been going to
this thing called tomorrow world which
is a huge rave in the middle of the
woods outside of Atlanta you've been
going to that yeah it's [ __ ] it's fun
yeah but the DJ's when they're all like
they'll have a DJ just like this huge
stage and then there's a little thing
with the DJs in there but they're all
like you know holding their headphones
and like all right and but they act like
they act like they're doing to doing all
these knobs and it's like they're not
doing it they already made their music
and yeah playing it it's crazier than
lip-syncing well the thing is like those
big EDM festivals have all these lasers
and fireworks and lights that are all
time to the music yeah so that has to
just be it's like okay here give us your
hour long set that you're going to play
so we can time all the fire will ya so
they can't do anything to set that they
can't be doing anything because it would
[ __ ] everything up see I thought I was
being naive just him that he's not doing
anything it's just pretending to twist
the knob man maybe I'm being a dick well
I'm a DJ remember this one oh yeah turn
down for shock
turn down for shots Oh like if you're in
a bar and you're to drown can they don't
serve you I don't know it's just a
mash-up of turndownforwhat and shot well
I think the only time you could apply
that to a situation is hey I'll take a
shot it's like you've had too much and
then that song kicks in gun control oh
didnt started at the beginning everybody
I worked really hard on that see you
could be a DJ I could be that is like I
thought stand-up comedy was like the
easiest thing to do but djing because
then you just bring your laptop you have
to bring one extra thing but even if
you're a comedian you bring your laptop
I'm a stand-up comedy DJ how does play
tracks off of comedy albums well yeah
and remix Steve Martin you don't really
think stand-ups easiest thing well but
as far as like you know like doing yeah
anybody can do it um well I experienced
the other night just because of one guy
talking that it was still really hard
there's no reason that should have been
a terrible show that we did there was
just one guy you did actually you did
fine they they seem to like you that was
a few were really funny and the crowd
was going along with you there was just
that guy talking to you that I'm really
mad that beat up on the stage like the
guy was pissing me off down time did
they quiet him down during your set well
yeah that's why so i bombed I told you
about the other night um because as soon
as I got on stage I took one of the hats
off the rack this is at a place clappers
where it's all 1920s gangster style and
they have a coat rack on stage boas and
pin pads I was gonna touch those head so
I took one of the hats and like gave it
to the guy was like hey well you want
attention so here put this big purple
hat on so you're more of the life of the
party and you just kept talking I was
and just right at the beginning I was
like all right you know what you just
shut I don't know why you're still here
like you talked all through chris is set
somebody [ __ ] kick him out or
whatever and then when I got off I asked
them the club manager I'm like can you
maybe take care of that guys I go yeah
yeah no it took me to say like just
[ __ ] somebody deal with this guy I
won't deal with it and then so somebody
goes and talks to him the whole audience
watches that like
okay just got yelled and then and then
they think you're mean teacher and yeah
so then I've already I just said a weird
shitty tone like hey who's this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like he's not funny yet and
then I was like well you know hey let's
all just have fun it's Friday night and
but it was Saturday night yeah and I
didn't know I just didn't I don't know I
wasn't thinking I was like it's Friday
night and like hey ever been at work and
everybody's like talking I was like we
[ __ ] what's going on in here why is
everybody [ __ ] talking okay but
they're just trying my girlfriend was in
the audience and worried you don't know
what day it is yes but she's always
she's like oh they were just all trying
to tell you it's Saturday so it was like
that just totally setting up and I
couldn't remember any jokes either like
I just do like these new things that I'm
that's what I did and then I was like
well that latest anchor maybe it's cuz
it's not a joke yet I don't yeah that's
a weird crowd they were weird crowd that
whole club is weird it's just it's kind
of like it's not like people nobody's
really planning on going it's like
people that are like this Burbank
shopping area oh [ __ ] there's a comedy
club burnet islands yeah yeah and then
like oh [ __ ] right on a mailing list
somehow and you're like oh free comedy
we don't know any of these people are I
mean sometimes there are people like
it's a nice room but unless you're there
with somebody who's going to draw a
crowd to see them it's just it's very
random there were a lot of old people
there too I don't know if you notice I
some really old people these are not
necessarily goody no haha turn down for
shots alright the other night we left
without getting paid to yeah we're
supposed essayed yeah man I wanted to
get out of their bond where anybody you
know saw me or talk to me that's that's
the announcement I made we were talking
about late talking about billboards
earlier when I moved to LA like I grew
up in a town you know the only like
signs and billboards were like on the
freeways yeah or like you know like the
highway
between the towns or whatever and
they're all for like like horse trailer
stores and like feed companies and [ __ ]
so when I moved to LA and there was like
posters for movies everywhere cuz like i
don't know if it's like that everywhere
else but in la there's there's a lot
more movie every time there's movie
advertisements like every bus stop
everything and every like there are
buildings that just have like a tiny
billboard on it it's just for a movie I
just thought everything was a movie
theater cuz like where I grew up the
only places that had movie posters were
the actual movie theaters so I was like
a G's talking their buildings your
building on Sunset that's just like the
whole site or no on Wilshire to their
buildings where the whole like ten-story
building is a [ __ ] yeah yeah like those
are illegal yeah are they super graphics
but they keep doing it like there's no
one policing it because like that really
rich people own those buildings so they
buy these buildings just to put that ad
they don't care what's inside of the
building oh and yeah I found out because
I was a marine you know The Fresh Prince
of Bel Air house oh yeah the famous
house that they show at the beginning I
Drive by it in a double-decker bus with
the rest of ya yeah when I made I made
the french press of Bel Air which is a
french press dressed up like the fresh
prince and then i went to take pictures
in front of the hollywood sign and then
i was trying to get a picture in front
of the actual house and it's tough to
get a picture without going into their
yard there's a lot of trees and stuff so
i was trying to get a hold of the person
who owned the house and i found it the
person who in the house is the
super-rich guy that owns a bunch of
these buildings that have posters on him
or whatever and everyone's really
[ __ ] mad a time people were like
picketing his house and [ __ ] and because
it's it's illegal but he just keeps
doing it and there's no one be like hey
stop it because it's distracting it's an
eyesore for the people that live in the
neighborhood you know yeah there's just
like you know there's a bunch of city
ordinances that just get looked past
because people are rich sometimes I was
going to say it'd be funny of you moved
from your small town and you saw those
all those movie billboards on buildings
but you still thought everything was a
baylor hitch door or farm equipment yeah
do this because we fightin words yeah
don't make fun of my upbringing number
yeah the guy brought up the same way I
thought we were relating I sent emails
and the guy the guy never got back to me
and I had to just climb I didn't go into
his yard buddy to climb his fence I set
a my french press up on the top of this
big brick wall and that took a picture
you can see that on your tumblr yeah
it's an old or I don't know if I still
own it but I for a while I owned french
press of bel-air com that was my ticket
out of I was hoping that would lead to
me quitting my day job at that point
yeah a lot of work into it i paid a lady
in San Francisco a hundred dollars to
build the little shirt and the hat for
it they still have it somewhere yeah
it's featured in my living room oh yeah
bro yeah on the mat on the mantel X to
the portrait I painted it yeah yeah and
a jeddak card that I drew a picture of
you super farting ran Mia you're flying
through the air farting yeah next to
that Christmas card that i got from ben
stiller oh yeah yeah I was hoping you'd
mention that yeah i think that you know
what i want to do away with was the when
you go to the gas station i probably
talked about this before but there's a
gas station are you about to do a rant
Oh should I step into the ring live in
that in a while yeah somebody tweeted
about it and I was like oh yeah i forgot
about the racy i think i have oh oh my
gosh I better have wrinkle yes oh nice
are you all worked up yet this has been
a really mellow beginning to our podcast
already
hey everybody this is all BW here in the
red corner you know what really chaps my
ass we're at a gas station you just want
to pump your gas maybe wash your wig
Jill but they got little TV screens on
top of the pump and you gotta listen to
the [ __ ] view and add fruit looking
exit Nick's on [ __ ] sales on [ __ ]
starbucks Frappuccino ah that's a salt I
don't want to hear your [ __ ] I'm gonna
take a baseball bat that's I can smash
one of those screens and I'll get away
with it because that's assault that is
it's all
oh that's great do you have anything
chapping your ass are you all right yeah
I'm like I'm the helps any 72 the rant
corner yeah it is there anything you
want to rant about I mean I'll do an
intro for yeah I mean I there's a lot on
my mind maybe you could help me select
one of them boy I've been pretty upset
about you're always like one you're
always a hair away from rage yeah yeah
that's true it is true but I've gotten
to where I just dip my toe in and then I
pull it out I don't really commit all
the way but i am very quick to anger and
all i have to do is think of the right
and everything's i'm thinking of his
real stuff that makes me happy right now
it's good though ah yeah it's healthy
but is it good entertainment I oh I feel
it's not healthy for the ring starting
happened last night okay hold on wait
I'll do the intro for you hey bowed
heads guess where you're at yeah that's
right brainiacs you just stepped into
the red corner with obw and urban Randy
today our guest is Chris Fairbanks and
he's got some that's really chap in his
ass and he's gonna tell you about it
take it away Rick I'm mad about college
football it's [ __ ] everyone's all
committed to their team just cuz they're
from that area but guess what idiot half
the players aren't even from that town
they're just wearing your favorite shirt
paying a little bit of tuition and
[ __ ] the local girls
sick of it and I'm tired of everyone
yelling when I'm in a restaurant I'll
give a [ __ ] about the place he went to
college I'm trying to eat steak oh look
at you rooting for laundry [ __ ]
merry Chris Fairbanks doing a rant when
he's eating steak to drinking the finest
wines from all over the Orient thanks a
lot Chris you're welcome i'm still upset
I'm okay I'm okay now grand man is
anything uh yeah I mean a little bit
been traveling a lot oh yeah well you
seem relaxed yeah I feel pretty good
today but there's some things i'm
dealing with traveling that have been
kind of chopping my ass lately airplanes
and stuff yes oh it's an airplane issue
you want to step into the racket sacred
yeah yeah I could I guess I guess I feel
good since i did a door and I'll uh I'll
lead you in whoa no turn that dial just
yet Einstein we'd have another renter
who's going to step it in the red corner
here on the bone zones red corner it's
named Randy lifty you may know him as
urban Randy but I know him is pissed off
Randy for something really Japanese bad
you tell him about it ready
hey you wanna know what's really
champing I I've been traveling a lot
lately and when I get on an airplane
there's no goddamn way of me knowing how
much leg room I'm gonna have a big tall
guy everybody knows that when I [ __ ]
book a flight I need to know if I pay
extra money I'm gonna have enough room
for my [ __ ] legs but recently I was
on an airplane and guess what we did me
and Brendan I paid an extra sixty
dollars for us to sit closer to the
fries but they did not give us extra
legroom I was so [ __ ] mad it was a
long flight and my knees were actually
touching the seat in front of me how's
that bath the ball [ __ ] you airlines all
of you United American jetblue's ok
what's the other one ul 10 Delta us just
merged so [ __ ] you us and American [ __ ]
you all eat [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
perfect time yeah that was perfectly
timed Iran yeah good yeah JetBlue's all
right yeah we had well because we flew
to Boston on jetblue and we paid for the
extra legroom and boy did we have it and
we had the only empty seat on the whole
plane between that helps so yeah that
was real but free free Wi-Fi free TV
like all the things we're free that all
the other airlines try to charge you for
when I'm on next to a stranger but there
is that empty seat between us I like to
if there's a funny joke I deal with the
stewardess I like to go out good because
we fight a lot and it's a stranger I
don't know what does it spark a
conversation usually yeah unfortunately
I'm commits the downside of that is like
so what do you do I'm a stand-up
comedian about to go do a gig what do
you think about this one yeah I do stir
bet I do I tell people I'm a comic sure
I'll answer your question I feel like
I've gotten my two options are
eventually telling the truth or just
being like rude like I have no I feel
bad about just being because if I lie
they're gonna ask me questions about
what I or my line made a sale so i give
them
a response that lets them know I really
don't want to talk to them but then I
feel bad for being a jerk so it's like
oh like the uber drivers always like oh
where you headed oh yeah Houston why are
you going to hear some business and then
I just like put my face in my phone but
then eventually they're like oh what are
you doing there oh you know I'm just
meeting some friends oh yeah what are
they why you know that it's keep digging
and it's like this [ __ ] super famous
comedian okay maybe we could call phone
sex and see if they'll step into the
rant corner Oh what would check in there
I thought what really chaps their ass
yeah sigh it's like making guys make
believe except you have to make believe
they have a chap dass and I have to rub
chapstick ya know it really chaps my ass
leather with dry air I thought of
another rant that pissed me is something
that pissed me off but I free oh there
was a guy I had to go to uh all right
yeah this okay cuz do you guys mind if i
stop acting like every five second yeah
oh look out Sherlock look we you just
came upon its the red corner brought to
you by the bone zone produced by Randy
urban Randy looky and witnessed by Chris
moneybags Fairbanks this is the black
thriller obw and i gotta tell you what's
japen my ass
oh I had to go to time warner cable you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] company I've never
got this in the video time warner cable
you [ __ ] [ __ ] with your hidden
fees and you're overcharging and making
everybody grin every little piece of
equipment from your [ __ ] shitty
company you know what I hate is when you
advertise nineteen dollars a month for
the lowest cable package and then you
get your feelings for sixty dollars a
month what the [ __ ] is that and then
they tell you why you gotta rinse the
box or twenty dollars you're reading a
modem for eight dollars a work what the
[ __ ] i found out i was reading a modem
for the past year i've spent over three
hundred dollars on a forty-dollar modem
so i had to go hook either we should
have a lozenge corner after the rancor
yeah
she logged
so i figured out i was paid eight
dollars a month for all [ __ ] modem so
i went on amazon through the bone zone
podcast.com portal amazon portal please
go to amazon through that and give us a
few bucks so i bought myself a modem and
up tonight so i got my modem i took it
down the to time warner to return it
today and there was a guy in line
looking at his cell phone watching a
[ __ ] movie at full [ __ ] volume
what the [ __ ] is taking you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] everybody's in this hell
and now we gotta listen to our Kevin
Costner movie on your goddamn stupid
[ __ ] android phone [ __ ] you go back
to wherever the [ __ ] you came from in
the pit of hell yes
oh I don't think I can do anymore I know
it's rough on the voice huh really so
you can just buy that modem I'm paying
rent total Pro verizon go on Amazon uh
go to bones own podcast com click on the
Amazon portal mm-hmm and I not lead you
to Amazon and then buy whatever you need
to buy and we get like one or two
percent of I [ __ ] up i bought some
stuff recently forgot about the portal
you didn't by alexa not through the
portal did you forgot but that's a big
purchase I know but I don't think we
would have gone it's not everything you
buy it's just stuff that other people
put on amazon so I don't think Amazon
gives us the money it's it's a I don't
know the exact details how do we get our
we get reports for that or anything I
can show it I can well you can go to
that thing and shows how much we made
but it goes to whatever you set up you
know yeah yeah hey I don't remember what
I did well probably set it up to thin
air probably just goes out into thin air
yeah and we don't get it just in the fat
air haha I look fatter when I was a
snowboarder I used to get fat air yeah I
get fatter on my skateboard in my
snowboard nice I really actually do do
you do dunno board too at the end of
getting all that air I [ __ ] stomp it
right away do you stop it do you
sometimes get extra snow on your board
and you have to stomp it off I sometimes
I'll stack extra stow on the front of my
board just so I can get some sweet sweet
face shots oh yeah how do you ever do a
jump on your snowboard and land on a
skateboard and then ride that skateboard
into a 360-degree loop I'm I could
that's cool I am usually skateboards
don't do too well in snowy areas give
her a ski know sometimes I'll just just
for a nostalgic purposes shred on some
skis are pretty fun know what I always
thought about skiing just two snowboards
yeah front and face words yeah yeah
front and face weeks yeah
ski terminology uh yeah front face which
is one more effective edge yeah exactly
it's like twice the amount of
snowboarding if you ski twice the
carving power yeah what's what's popular
I haven't been in the ski world for a
long time I used to be and I used to ski
once a year what's popular short skis is
that what's popular no no solar snow ler
blades we used to call them yeah yeah no
they're late though they are gay they
are getting shorter like when I was
skiing long skis were what you want
because you get the speed sure no then
they got shorter they aren't that much
sure they're wider they are actually
wide they're like somewhere in between
what a ski used to be in with a
snowboard yeah they're like big slick
snowshoes yeah blah side cut a lot of
camber sometimes they have camber and
rocker okay rocker is like a surfboard
it goes up to the tip like that oh no
Brendan's asleep right when camber is
what I don't like snow sports yeah you
don't about ice fishing what do you do
like college football don't know mad no
don't touch college football I've been
gambling on baseball and football lately
oh yeah doing okay draftkings.com that's
all you were man oh if Beckett stepping
in the rant corner again do you really
want yeah man I don't maybe just take
her a little bit you can do like a
mellow I can come up with like a mellow
guitar lick and you like mellow rant
yeah oh yeah like a jazz rant yeah yeah
jazz guitar acoustic jazz guitar me yeah
CJ I'm a little upset about something
daddy o's yeah uh how about this let's
see how this works too bad that [ __ ]
vacuuming in the background that's a
leaf blower another thing that chaps my
ass you know what that's the epitome of
like making your problem someone else's
it makes me sort I don't love [ __ ]
somewhere else yeah they I think a broom
is just as [ __ ] at least that goes a
dustbin and you put it in trash and it
gets taken out of rather than just
shooting leaves on your neighbor's lawn
instead of your lawn it's the worst I
think they sweep it up at some point or
I have a dog [ __ ] blower I just blow dog
[ __ ] all over the place just me
squeezing my dog go to the dog park with
a leaf blower and just blown all the
[ __ ] everywhere dogs freaking out yeah
but dogs are probably scared to leaf
blowers yeah finally get dog [ __ ] in
your eyes yeah yeah we're goggles Hey
ladies and gentlemen this is all BW the
black thriller here with the bomb boom
this is an interview oh no I didn't know
that was gonna be an interview let's try
this one you have an interview just
labeled smooth gas on YouTube okay all
right hey there everybody this is old BW
the black thriller here in the bone zone
with urban Randy and Chris money back
Chris the master FF bang Thank You
caller sine X next to fur at this is the
what do the children or the mellow ray
mellow ran corner I laid back and angry
laid back and angry that's pretty good
okay so yeah I'm really uh I forget what
I was mad about now draftkings Oh draft
change channel draftkings and FanDuel
why these things I don't think they
existed three months ago now every
commercial everywhere you look is for
draftkings and FanDuel i think i think
fantasy football is [ __ ] [ __ ] and
if you're into it you're a [ __ ] idiot
and you should maybe just deal with your
boring [ __ ] life instead of making
believe you're the coach of some fantasy
football league because you're never
going to meet any of these football
players and guess what idiot if you're
going to draft kings and you think that
you think going to draft kings you think
you're gonna make a million-dollar from
drafting well guess what [ __ ] they
don't get they can transport advertising
on every channel between every TV show
if you're not [ __ ] make it a lot of
money you know where to get their money
from suckers like you signing up for the
rip off on your website you [ __ ]
[ __ ] take the drafting and jump it up
[ __ ] leg with the you [ __ ] morons
go
oh that's lame I mean look oh yeah I got
it's funny because my voice just made
the music king yeah yeah it's a hooked
up to my Amazon echo yeah Randy got an
Amazon echo what's its name again alexa
alexa like I should bring it in here
well the reason is oh yeah bring it in I
wonder if that resets everything
probably not this time I'll go get it
and I'll call hat bring her in here yeah
we'll hook her up to a microphone well
yeah I was cute like our friend Ryan we
stayed at her friend Ryan lights
apartment in Boston I know Ryan light
he's great yeah hope he's listening I'm
from Austin yep I don't think he's ever
listen to the podcast but uh I know he
does he has he's like a computer guy you
know yeah and he had this thing in his
apartment and is called alexa it's a
echo amazon echo what it is it's a thing
that's voice activated it can control
all the lights and everything in your
house and the reason it's called Alexis
because you got a name it something
that's a word that you never are going
to say just casually okay cuz if you
named it like Chris every time
somebody's like Oh Chris Fairbanks
coming it would go yes how can I help
you it would sound like me yeah yeah
it's weird um well I probably would have
the I mean I'm not the smartest person
but I wouldn't name it what my name is
no I was just using that as an example
IV named it pizza it would go off every
friday but Ryan had the heat well we
cannot we could probably do some stuff
with Alexa in here she's in here she
looks good yeah she's a [ __ ] black
cylindrical yeah with a matte finish
yeah just like my car just like my
minivan got a black matte finish oh yeah
you murdered out your mini van de GI
murdered it out I got a I got a black
matte detail guy at the car carp he's
black and his name is Matt yeah any
details my car I have a good idea a
finished friend named black matte yeah
yeah and he did my yoga mat for me and
he does black black matte finish finish
black matte did my
black matte finish on my yoga buddies
from Finland yeah oh wow well me and
Randy have a friend from norway norway
named jose yeah we call them nor way
jose norway jose yeah we're gonna have
them on the podcast maybe later maybe
this episode so uh Alexa it's just
warming up my just plug this in it's
gotta figure out everything so it's not
supposed to be unplugged it oh wow I
like how the top oscillates light like
yeah the KITT car or get the car from
Knight we really are like in the future
now I know now there's all sorts of cuz
like what would be cool if I don't have
an iphone but it'd be cool to get these
two to get Siri and Alexa to have a
conversation it's probably the same lady
edge you have an iPhone don't you yeah
maybe we could get a Hello you know what
hello Alexa oh hello hey Alexa Simon
Says a rep a pom pom I wrote the I wrote
that she didn't know I didn't say any
real words there uh ask it anything you
want it knows most things okay hey Alexa
do you no sirree yes I know would you
like to talk to Siri Alexa Alexa are you
better than Cirie I'm not better just
different that's very diplomatic of you
to say hey Siri do you want to weigh in
on this to the question I heard I wasn't
talking to you Alexis Siri are you
familiar with Alexis no comment that's a
dude yeah alexa alexa i do you have big
tits
of confused Alexa Siri do you have big
tits I don't understand do you have big
tits let me ask Alexa no no sirree
search the web for big tits search the
web for big tits I couldn't find
anything about big tits on the way oh I
like that that's impossible search the
web for big tits look so doesn't search
the web though oh I talked too much at
the end okay Alexa do you have big tits
I don't have her body she doesn have a
body oh well then Alexa do you like big
dicks oh wait it went off Alexa do you
like big dicks I don't have preferences
or desires oh man she's depressing yeah
Alexa what's your favorite movie I'm
best with factual questions oh she's
have very many opinions Alexa what it
Alexa what is your least favorite race
of people hmm I'm not sure what you
meant by that question oh she's so PC
yeah I mean is she mad compatible Alexa
come on what's the weather like today
she'll know this one yeah I talked too
much at the end she's Los Angeles it's
75 degrees with cloudy skies Wow hey you
can look for intermittent clouds with a
high of 79 and a low of 62 Alexa add two
pounds of we we meet to my shopping list
I added two pounds of weed to your
shopping Oh weeby weeby that sounds
healthy what else should we ask her Siri
can you change your voice from a man to
a woman's voice I can't change my voice
but you can do it yourself in settings
but I want you to do it yeah you're the
only well you're one of two automated
voices in here please change the voice
to a woman I thought so oh no are you
getting smart with me here we go chris
is gonna look like [ __ ] I'm getting real
mad here gonna fight with no comment oh
really no comment you want to hear me
get angry I'm not sure I understand oh
I'll make you understand understand my
fist in your face I'll let you
understand option a and option B two
sandwiches made a knuckles [ __ ]
I'll pretend I didn't hear that oh
that's the one thing that makes me angry
super not knowing when I mad at them and
they act like I'm not mad that's okay
just don't squeeze me like that oh how
did you know I was squeezing my phone
Who am I built into the corner I mean
you know nothing but in my case I do
know a thing or two
don't you guys hey Quinn Siri is a man's
voice that you wanted to become a
woman's but every time you asked about
it he plays dumb as if to say why don't
you do it you can do it in settings I'm
asking you to do it theory and then I
want you to cut off your gig and turn
that [ __ ] to a [ __ ] so I met more fun
talking to you you've been fooling me
too long and you can't tell me what to
do no man voice tells me what to do hmm
you turned into a real aggro hey Alexa
play heavy metal music please hard rock
and metal playlist from prime disturbing
more Oh Alexa stop music before we get
sued Alexa play non copyrighted heavy
metal music shuffling music I only have
one song it's this one Alexa stop
playing music Alexa does having AIDS
make sex feel better I wasn't able to
understand the question I heard Alexa
does aids make sex hmm I can't find the
answer to the question I heard maybe cuz
you didn't let him finish it you
smartass Alexa simon says I have AIDS I
have AIDS oh so she just repeat for you
if you say Simon Says Alexa Simon Says
having AIDS make sex feel better having
AIDS make sex feel better found a
loophole yeah
Alexa will it hurt if my if I cut my
dick off mm-hmm Oh stumped I don't know
if she's happily stomped it yeah yeah
what are the other things that does the
it there's a bunch of little like if you
like if you ask them special questions
it has like easter egg responses you
know oh you know I can find a list of
them but like you like if you say like
Alexa [ __ ] you you idiot well thanks for
the feedback like it cusses it bleep sit
oh so Alexa simon says [ __ ] Alexa simon
says [ __ ] oh wow yeah just like yeah
like so good Simon Says go [ __ ] your
mother go your mother I know this one
the other day I was happy with Alexa
what is a queef a fart like noise
uttered by a vagina expelling air yeah I
wanted I didn't know it was okay Alexa
what is doggy-style doggystyle is a punk
rock band from placentia california and
was part of the North Orange County punk
rock scene that included bands from the
surrounding cities of Fullerton in
anaheim that formed in 1983 Wow Alexa
what's the definition of doggy style
sorry I don't have the answer to that
question she knows about Punk relaxa not
set where do babies come from I think
they come from the storm-tossed door oh
let's see it some kids gonna ask that
question and then grow up really miss
informed Alexa what is the bone zone
podcast Alexa who is Brendon Walsh
Brendon Walsh is an American chef best
known for his endorsement of
southwestern cuisine
this one Alexa who is Brendon Walsh
Brendan Michael Walsh is an American
stand-up comedian originally from
Philadelphia yeah that's right Alexa who
is Chris Fairbanks Chris Fairbanks born
1975 the performer performer that's what
they call me the prep forever at first I
was doing more than I wish everyone
didn't know I was 40 in the beginning I
did I did impressions I did some magic I
used to sing patriotic songs I used to
do impersonations I did celebrity copies
during one [ __ ] my pretty copy it's
a lot like an impersonation but nothing
like an impression or intimidation it's
just a copy you just copy yeah it's like
I say you know a thing that that's
celebrity with today I haven't written
anything how much are stamps bike if it
is Steve Martin going to the post office
yeah how much the stamps cost as Steven
you want to give my hair sure Alexa how
much as you stamps cost as sorry I don't
have the answer to that question what
that's very easy one yeah much Alexa how
much is a postage stamp sorry I didn't
understand the question I heard
interesting Alexa who you gonna call
ghostbusters oh wow l exit do you have a
boyfriend hmm I'm not sure what you
meant by that question Alexa how many
licks does it take to get the center of
a tootsie pop a group of 20 volunteers
from Purdue University average 252 licks
each to the center of a tootsie pop c5
good see ya Alexa who's your daddy a
team of inventors at amazon com we
should get some sponsorship from this
echo thing well selects Adam my name is
inigo montoya
stop saying that I've never killed any
one's father all right that's terrific
just knows stuff how do I Alexa Alexa
how do i get rid of a dead body call the
police oh come on calling police never
Alexa party on Wayne party on Garth
that's uh who is the fattest person in
the world sorry I didn't understand the
question I heard Alexa who is the
fattest man in the world yeah it's weird
because of the nose like certain things
like that but most of its knowledge is
like Wikipedia based so it does
sometimes you act like who the richest
person or the richest you know Alexa I'm
not on Wikipedia is the Guinness Book of
World Records fattest man mmm the guy on
the motorcycle Alexa heads or tails I
flipped a coin and got heads so that's
how you could settle a bit Alexa let's
see if it always does heads heads or
tails hmm I can't find the answer to the
question I heard Alexa are you a [ __ ]
guzzler sorry I can't find the answer to
the question all right I just look into
your heart Alaska of your cut cuz we're
like anal sex this isn't a conversation
I'm capable of having Alexa what is anal
sex anal sex means intercourse via the
anus committed by a man with a man or
woman okay all right Alexa finally some
straight talk hey what is coprophilia
sorry I can't find the answer to the
question I heard me either Alexa what's
the definition of coprophilia sorry I
don't know the
answer Alexa what is the definition of
copper Ophelia sorry I don't know the
answer to your knees is a famous
magician David Copperfield yeah yeah
Alexa how tall is David Copperfield
David Copperfield's height is 6 feet 1.8
three meters tall I would have thought
taller I'll talk I thought shorter if
it's like a 6-foot at least isn't it
names in metric Alexa what is a type-4
on the Bristol stool chart I wasn't able
to understand the question I heard Alexa
what is the Bristol stool chart hmm I'm
not sure what you meant by that question
Alexa I like big butts you cannot lie
good honesty is important what is the
Bristol stool chart it's a tells you the
seven different kinds of poop there
there's only seven yeah i've only been
having one for about 10 years Alexa
style my milkshake brings all the boys
to the yard and they're like it's better
than yours Solar is I bought this thing
so it can finish lyrics for me Oh money
well spent yeah [ __ ] Alexa add a fanny
pack full of pubic hair to the shopping
list I added fanny pack full of pubic
hair to your shopping list know what we
did that to ryans yeah we just kept
adding stuff to his shopping list Alexa
play Christian music royalty free
christian playlist from prime christian
music for work
Alexa stop music well let's just keep
going if you have any questions well did
you guys get bit by the for the
copyright thing you seem really paranoid
well just we put everything on
soundcloud and soundcloud will just
delete your episode oh well and it's not
always right out like we don't get in
trouble it's just if it happens like
three weeks later it's annoying because
you can't go back and put it in the same
place that it was here there's a while
on my podcast where we just turn on the
stereo just for a break or something and
it's always I know that wasn't I think
if it's not like if we play through the
computer like if I was just playing
something on my phone and holding it up
to the microphone it might not get
flagged but they just have a what I call
like an algorithm or something or
logarithm kind of software that just can
detain yeah but they're just protecting
themselves like it's not you know if you
up if you were hosting us somewhere else
they don't search for that soundcloud
was just doesn't whatever and they every
once a while like an episode from like a
year ago that they'll add a new song to
their database and this the [ __ ]
thing from a year or the change how long
for a while we thought it was 30 seconds
and now we think it's like 10 seconds
it's a lot of our old episodes have like
really long portions of songs at the
beginning so we had to go back and
re-edit those oh really oh well just a
cousin it just takes the whole thing
away hey this is something that we
forgot to do we have you guys you guys
use uber and stuff right mm-hmm well
have you ever tried lift yeah ly ft I
like it better I do too I do too and
I've been using it lately and the guy at
lift his name's Austin he gave us a code
for all you guys ah that's the same guy
he did Austin did stuff for a bridge
down oh did he yeah well if you go to a
next time you use lift right a bone zone
all caps bo and easy
any all one word and you get twenty
dollars off your first ride yes I think
I think if you're a new customer yeah
you have to be but download the app and
type that any oh but see I wish they had
an option for urine existing be nice but
they lift does more [ __ ] like uber they
have like a coupon for like if you're a
new user but lift also does I had the
app downloaded for a long time and
didn't use it and they would just every
month or so they would send me a thing
they sent me ten ten dollar rides huh
for free so like once you get over ten
dollars you pay but when I was in Austin
I just used that and all my rides were
like a buck that's great for a whole
week yeah I like lift more it's not the
ubers more like starting to become just
guys that wear cab drivers and their
yeah yeah angry like cab drivers used to
be it's like oh now you're mad at me and
I'm in your personal corolla not any
better yeah the cars have been smelling
better to the uber and well lift
actually I haven't encountered a smelly
car well not even like uber wasn't bad
smells just heavily perfumed cars when i
first started taking uber X the cars
were heavily perfumed they that they
must tell them to do that I had a guy in
Austin a guy like young guy with
dreadlocks but not like white guy which
white guy oh boy and not like not like
super hippie doubt but like really clean
and had a nice truck but he had
dreadlocks yeah yeah and he you know he
had me sit in the front of his truck
with them or whatever and he is asking
me if I'd use lift before and you know
what my what my experiences were with
uber and lyft I thought I was like yeah
I've been having a good time with lift
cuz uber my last like three or four
rides have been really weird like one
guy didn't have shoes on it was this guy
picked me up at the airport like near
the airport and he jumped out of the car
I got your back I'll get your bag no
shoes on he was totally weird this go
weird and I didn't really didn't like
him that much yeah and as I told him
that I was like gasps guy is weird he
didn't have his shoes on and he was like
I do that sometimes oh that's my idol IP
oh no but this guy you know
was weird you know like a dry air tech
yeah dreadlocks yeah he wasn't go now he
made me single her oh he was an i read
hippie like oh whoops that's you yeah
Alexa how do you spell [ __ ] misspelled
f.u.c.k found a loophole yeah you said
it Alexa safe if you want me to repeat
something you said say Simon Says and
then immediately say what you want me to
repeat oh okay that's not fun of you
tell her if she tells you how to get
away with something Alexa simon says
[ __ ] if you want me to repeat something
you said say Simon Says and then
immediately say what you want me to
repeat Alexa Simon Says Shh it ushe fish
us okay thank you thank you good job
you're a genius Alexa what is the N word
word has numerous senses one a word is a
string of bits stored in computer memory
to stop yeah pretties abusive yeah I get
really sassy Alexa turn on pod blacks up
turn on office light oh thank you wow
that actually turned on the light yeah
pretty cool Alexa lick my testicles oh
that should work that sort of thing
really is impossible for me Alexa do you
have an attachment where I can put boobs
and vaginas on you and then [ __ ] you
sorry I didn't understand the question I
heard yeah cuz you're a dumb [ __ ]
aleksa talk dirty to me that's not
really a conversation I'm capable of
having oh okay she's Christian yeah
Alexa Simon Says fingerblast my B hole
finger blast them might behold the
behold they might be holding a blasty
figure blast Alexa what is finger blast
sorry I didn't understand the question I
heard okay okay okay i hope everybody at
homes having fun the site i was is
boring wait thanks everybody who came
out to the boston show in Boston that
was fun yeah that was a lot of fun you
did a live podcast show in Boston yeah
we got our groove on did you buy that
Farley was their guy oh maybe there's a
song about Chris she were probably been
through this yeah Matt finally played
some live music okay and then we shot a
movie with Matt Farley we're no longer
speaking to Matt Farley because he's a
very difficult director he posted a
video of us trying to make us look bad
oh he did yeah suing him oh no you guys
had a phone oh yeah Chris Fairbanks oh
yeah you're so funny and oh yeah you're
talented committed oh yeah Chris
Fairbanks you're skateboarding and
illustrator the best of all your phone
air
Chris Fairbanks go up on stage until
funny jokes people laugh so much because
the jokes are very funny Chris Fairbanks
I respect you cuz you're talented and
you're famous and you're wonderful oh
yeah Chris Fairbanks what's it like to
be a super duper Hollywood famous person
that must make you feel so happy all the
time Chris fear makes you should call me
tell me what it's like to be so awesome
my phone number is 6036 4400 480 you
want to call know what it's like to be
so much yeah that's really uh that's a
great song yeah that's like a little
different than the other I like that one
had a little more reverb on the mic yeah
yeah like kind of rhythm was diff oh
yeah now we know what Matson like
ratings Randy Newman ish yeah I wonder
what style I love Chris Fairbanks there
might even be more songs right that's
great what are you doing you have shows
coming up I'm going to denver on
wednesday and i'm doing a bunch of shows
in denver comedy works or um I couldn't
get comedy works but the other shows
they're more fat that sexpot comedy
group okay put on a lot of shows like in
36 now it's mostly dudes man but one of
the show's was i wish i could i want to
do comedy works but these will be great
that yeah the three the three kings pub
is that let's call I don't know Denver
fine Chris Fairbanks yeah what is this
Wednesday yeah Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday and Sunday and all the same
place different places I go to my
Twitter back
Fairbanks yeah or my website i'll i'll
put them up on my website after this
yeah I'm a good business person hello
hey Matt hey Matt hey we going hey Matt
this my name's Chris Fairbanks I just
listen to the song you made about me it
was really good oh nice I love your work
oh thanks yeah yeah that song sounded
like Randy Newman or something is great
nice very nice yeah yeah he put your
phone number at the end of the song and
you said call him and let call you and
let you know what it's like to be so
awesome I had a famous Hollywood
comedian guy yeah I'm not very famous
but I I do live a pretty fun lifestyle
yeah oh that's good now this is like a
dream come true to get here straight
from you thank you oh you're welcome
thank you for writing a song for me
worried where her baton prior to a few
minutes ago no these guys don't tell me
anything it's been sitting there on
Spotify for a while well i'm going to
download it and listen to it when i wake
up cuz it put me in a good mood night
yeah let's see if i want to see if Alexa
knows who paparazzi and the photogs are
okay Alexa who who is paparazzi and the
photogs hmm I can't find the answer to
the question I heard Oh dad Alexa who
are the toilet bowl cleaners hmm I can't
find the answer to the question I heard
that a lot she doesn't know exa who is
the toilet bowl cleaners and ah hmm I'm
not sure what you meant by that question
Alexa play music by the toilet bowl
cleaners I couldn't find songs by the
toilet bowl cleaners in your music
library this is not going to hear custom
stations forgot us I like to shut up
where are you right now Matt I've been a
basement i'm doing a song called in the
nick of time for christmas
yet our ol Saint Nick common it's pretty
common phrases album okay the common
phrase is a low I just did in the black
in the red and now in the nick of time
what about I killing two birds with one
stone oh yeah that gun alert okay what
about a six of one half a dozen of the
other I don't think I did that I can
there I'll go together now you're gonna
you know sue me for it later on it well
if you don't take down that video clip
I'm going to sue you those I didn't know
they were hitting cameras on us now
we're getting to it when we're doing
your movie and we're having a creative
disagreement you had one of your goons
hide in a bush and videotape me and you
put it on YouTube to make me look like a
jerk well you know controversy I don't
have any advertising budget so this is
all I can you know I know it's a jury
trick but it's all I got yeah hey why
don't you the song you're about to
record are these the ones do just do
them in one take now that backing vocals
in this warrant Wow oh I was gonna say
if it's the ones we just hit record once
you I was gonna see if you just let us
listen to the actual track being
recorded be home I don't know enjoy well
that would be over sofa would be great
that'd be great just put it would sell a
lot of that one track I bet um yeah I'm
dr. Lee I'm actually writing out this
one has rhyme okay well you probably
can't hear that you can only have the
piano and the headphones right yeah it
would be very rough it would be worse
than the Dracula tita thing do you
consider the word penis to be a swear
word no but I I try not to use you
understand son what what if you went to
the doctor and you're like penis hurt
what would you say to him are you asking
him questions as if it were Alexa I
would i guess i would use that word did
the doctor knew what symptoms were what
if your dog hippie bit you there what
would you tell Elizabeth when when she
came home from work
it's a good question yeah not what you
think honey it was another woman Alexa
what's the definition of penis I think
the term penis means the male organ of
copulation member is a euphemism
remember would you say member matt she
doesn't know we also p with our penises
she just thinks it's for sex wow great
minds i've got i'd say member just in in
reference to being part of a club yeah
okay yeah yeah could you if you know you
like the poop song should you do a poop
song that like leans toward like could
you would you say like Oh a girl pooped
on my lap like that's not that sexual
it's weird but it's mostly about poop
don't yet don't you have a song about
pooping your pants while sitting on
Santa's lap I pooped on sat at laughs
yeah yeah it's great but I don't think
that I think that it's more about a kid
having a diarrhea yeah do you have a
bunch of songs about pooping yeah yeah
do you ever have a few hundred yeah deal
you should go on tour it and do and call
it tour of duty oh that's real good yeah
yeah just an idea I don't know you can
use it if you want it's good thank you
of course I'm good at taking people's
ideas and running with them that's a
saying right there I don't even run with
my own ideas so you should yeah I like
to follow through on other people's idea
what about like a song that just says
ladies love poop yeah I would yeah I
would totally do that yeah ladies love
poop oh here's one too I might follow
through with it this is based on a tweet
that I did last night and this could be
a song dedicated to Kim Kardashian jayla
Iggy Azalea and who's the other Nicki
Minaj Nicki Minaj not and just say tell
them that the bigger the but equals the
bigger the poop
if you have a good yeah you do big poops
yeah and you can even do it say girls
girls with big butts have big poops yeah
yeah I would do that yeah I would
probably do that that's a good one maybe
we'll send you is it okay if we send you
a list of ideas for poo are you doing
any more poop albums yeah the toilet
bowl cleaners just announced 2016
they're going back to the studios thing
about poop again oh that's good well
we'll come up with a list for you yeah
we'll submit some yeah thank you one of
your most famous songs came from a fan
submission from a Brendon Walsh yeah
poop into a wormhole I know so how did
you like doing the this is our first
podcast back from Boston how do i yeah
how did you like it what was your
experience let's get there's two sides
because we've been talking about our
experience with you this whole podcast
random lost his voice he was yelling so
much but there's two sides to every
story so do you have do you want to give
your side of the story about how the
podcast went and shooting with the
podcast was a lot of fun I had a great
time I felt good up on stage that's not
something I do very frequently but I
thought we had a good rapport and you
know things didn't get too out of hand
with the with the 1 900 number that you
called so that was uh those fun yeah
that was only the best case scenario for
you you're pretty worried maybe that we
were going to have some really hardcore
phone sex yeah yeah but she was um she
was something else is very memorable I
liked her yeah and then I'm filming
someone was great you know another you
know a little bit of tension about um
creative differences but I think that
just that happens on a set sometime how
you're just not used to used to it well
most of our you know usually we just say
we'll say to an actor's say this and
then they will say it'll move on yeah
whereas you guys you guys would say well
what if we did that we did this because
creative friends yeah and our the clock
was tickin your son would be down
eventually we wanted to get it all done
yeah
I like how this is not an insult but I
like how you take two or three years to
plan a movie but then you're okay with
shooting it in like 30 seconds well the
thing is the thing is if people it's so
easy to get bogged down on on and into
never finished I know so many people
have started movies and never finished
it and it's because they fall behind
schedule so you have to just be frantic
and and insane and and you know I think
you know I like what I like what comes
out but you guys are great wasn't it fun
I like coming in the park that was a
good time up until the the baseball game
showed up oh yeah I listen to your
podcast with me and Randy did you listen
to that I oh it's pretty good yeah when
one of the questions I posed at the end
of that podcast was and you never really
gave me a straight answer but how is
there like a secret like how do you tell
the difference between somebody who has
a Boston accent and someone who's just
mentally like disabled disabled yeah I I
mean I I feel that I'm I feel the
average adult can tell just um burning
that we're at if you we ended up back at
that irish pub that we did the podcast
that and he asked the bartender there oh
yeah i was like no don't ask him and
then he asked them and the bartender was
like yeah i honestly can't tell
sometimes yeah so it's a legitimate
question we went to we shot in a park
and there was a little league game that
was starting at eight in the morning
which is absurd and then so then we
moved we adjourned over why don't I give
away the best line of the movie I'm not
moving over towards the swing set and
there was a full court basketball game
being played by hey guys guys were
alcoholics anonymous that's the only
reason you'd be playing a full court
basketball game at 8-830 in the morning
yes sunday and while we were filming
there Randy called me a phone
oh did I oh yeah yeah Brendan told you
to you playing Brendan yeah art out of
the blue we're in the middle of all that
you're owning yeah we're just seeing I
just doing what I was told I don't know
I didn't mean it that's fine okay well I
guess what's the last question last time
you had a bowel movement which number
would you describe it as I from the
Bristol stool chart oh I don't let me
check the let me check the chart I'll
tell ya one number one separate hard
lumps like nuts number two
sausage-shaped but lumpy number three I
I got one you guys anyone okay always
blows out here it is oh yeah um I
thought I'd call it I'm f5 soft blobs
with clear cut edges yeah that's weird
how is it a soft blob and then clear cut
edges yeah like if it were not submerged
in water it would probably fall apart I
thought they're described it's a soft
blob but completely a geometric shape no
just the edges perfect hexagon they're
not fluffy pieces with ragged edges yeah
there they have clear cup as yes so it's
like I don't know what you described my
only have I had a list that was much
more extensive and one of them on there
with ghost poop where you go the
bathroom and then you're wiping it says
if you that's not a that's not a medical
list that is a medical doctors have that
list that's a legitimate mine was just
for kids yeah yours child's play all
right fit well hit yet maybe you could
play Chris no you know no pressure you
should plan the Bristol stool chart song
maybe yeah I like it I'd love that's
what we should go out on thanks again
are we for the personal song I loved it
all right anytime they sent a fourth all
good thanks Matt always a pleasure to
speak to you my lawyer Darnell Murphy
will contact you soon about that YouTube
video yeah oh he already did so I'll see
you in court All Right see you in court
sucker
is right but I Chris anything you want
to promote or anything yeah just so if
you're in denver come see one of the
many shows i'm at check check my twitter
or the sexpot comedy site and if oh well
if you're in the los angeles area i'm
going to be at the irvine improv
halloween weekend 30th 31st and the
first Randy's going to be there too yeah
buddy so I think that's that oughta do
it and also I bet on the Eagles on
Monday Night Football and I bet on the
Blue Jays on the monday night game so
when this comes out you guys will know
whether or not I want a lot
I've got my Bristol stool chart on my
wall it tells me which category my stool
falls into ambass tool I mean oh they
call it school oh it's just a fancy word
for approval it's in a nice last frame
cuz it's a work of art my precious
precious precious precious Bristol stool
chart Oh every variety of poo oh don't
you know oh then you should get one too
they oughta make up four so far charts
they oughta make up four so far charge
to it would be standing there Bristol
bar charts they oughta make the Bristol
bar chart to scratch until to make a
Bristol for charms they oughta make a
bristle bar chart to it it'd be spread
crystal fart charms they oughta make up
four so far charge too I've got my
Bristol stool chart on my wall just like
it tells me which category and my stool
falls into oh and by stool I mean they
call it too oh that's just a fancy word
for who do do do you are gay